Narrator: FROM 100-BILLION STARS
RACING TOWARDS US...
...THE ANDROMEDA GALAXY.
SCIENTISTS HAVE LONG SUSPECTED
IT WILL ONE DAY
CRASH INTO OUR GALAXY,
THE MILKY WAY.
TONY'S PRECISE MEASUREMENTS
ALLOW HIM TO PREDICT
HOW THIS CLASH OF THE TITANS
WILL LOOK.
TO ANYONE ON EARTH,
IT WOULD BE A SPECTACULAR SIGHT.
Sohn:
WE'LL SEE THE ANDROMEDA GALAXY
GETTING BIGGER
AND BIGGER IN THE SKY.
AND THEN EVENTUALLY, IN ABOUT
FOUR BILLION YEARS FROM NOW,
WE'LL SEE THE COLLISION
OF THE TWO GALAXIES.
♪♪
Narrator: ON IMPACT,
CLOUDS OF DUST WILL BE
CRUSHED TOGETHER
WITH SENSATIONAL RESULTS.
WHAT WE'LL SEE IS A LOT
OF STARS GETTING FORMED.
AND THIS WILL LOOK
SOMETHING LIKE
STELLAR FIREWORKS IN THE SKY.
Narrator:
TONY CAN EVEN CALCULATE THE ODDS
THAT OUR SOLAR SYSTEM
WILL CRASH INTO ONE
OF ANDROMEDA'S BILLIONS OF STARS
DURING THE COLLISION.
SURPRISINGLY,
THE PROGNOSIS IS GOOD.
Sohn: GALAXIES
ARE ESSENTIALLY EMPTY SPACE.
SO THE CHANCES OF STARS
COLLIDING WITH ANOTHER STAR
IS VERY SLIM,
BECAUSE THE DISTANCE
BETWEEN THE STARS IS VAST.
SO WHEN THE COLLISION HAPPENS,
THE SOLAR SYSTEM WILL PASS
THROUGH AN EMPTY SPACE
BETWEEN THE STARS.
Narrator: AFTER PASSING
LIKE GHOSTS IN THE NIGHT,
THE IRRESISTIBLE PULL OF GRAVITY
WILL DRAW THEM BACK TOGETHER
OVER THE NEXT TWO-BILLION YEARS
TO FINALLY SETTLE AS A NEW
SUPERGALAXY NICKNAMED MILKOMEDA.
OUR GALAXY WILL NO LONGER EXIST.
YET CALCULATIONS SUGGEST
THE SOLAR SYSTEM WILL SURVIVE.
Sohn: IT WILL MERGE INTO
ONE BIG GALAXY,
AND IT WILL LOOK LIKE
A GIANT BALL IN THE SKY.
Narrator: SADLY, IT'S UNLIKELY
ANYONE WILL BE ON EARTH
TO WITNESS THIS COLOSSAL
GALACTIC COLLISION.